pas forcément vous vous en doutez le
quotidien est un petit peu bouleversé
notamment quand on a deux enfants deux
enfants plus en plus haut en bas âge que
le petit à 17 mois il est il est en
crèche à la grande à cinq ans et demi
elle est en grande section maternelle en
voilà cet âge là on s'est pas forcément
s'occuper tout seul alors heureusement
pour l'aîné il ya sa maîtresse qui nous
envoie tous les matins les devoirs à
faire et mine de rien en grande section
de maternelle qui a quand même pas mal
de petits exercices à faire notamment ce
ne serait ce que la date en fait du jour
voilà écrire la date du jour même pour
nous j'ai envie de dire sa douceur parce
qu'on sait plus trop quel jour on est
avec elle voilà avec ce ce confinement
donc voilà pas mal de petits exercices à
faire le bémol bien sûr c'est comme pas
mal voilà deux personnes qui vivent en
région parisienne là je suis je suis
dans un appartement
donc c'est un petit peu compliqué pour
les normalement les temps de récréation
alors bien sûr heureusement j'ai la
chance d'avoir un petit balcon d' 1 m
sur 6 voilà c'est quand même pas
suffisant pour les grandes phases de la
trottinette
on met du coup voilà bah on fait du
ballon dans les dents dans le couloir
par exemple voilà ce que l'âme est très
soudé qu'il faut à peu près 30 minutes
et d'activité physique
et puis alors le manque aussi pour ta
maman je pense pour les enfants qui sont
qui sont à l'école passaient les copains
et les copines
pour nous ce qu'on a fait par exemple
c'est qu'on a créé sur sur what's app en
groupe
justement avec tous les tous les parents
et tous les jours du coup on envoie des
photos nos enfants voilà pour qu'ils
puissent se voir et puis maintenir un
petit peu ce ce lien entre voilà avant
la reprise
ça aussi ça la grande question savoir
maman quand est-ce que l'école va
rouvrir la voie là on essaie d'expliquer
avec avec des mots simples
voilà qui vaut mieux rester chez soi
pour pas pour pas être malade et puis
surtout pour pas voilà véhicule et le
virus donc voila tout se passe bien en
tout cas de mon côté on sait pas encore
et ripper